sie haben vielleicht gerade schon im
Verlauf der Sendung gemerkt dass ich
mich mir große Sorgen mache was in
unserem Land gerade passiert und nicht
erlebt aus persönlichen Gesprächen im
bekannten und Kollegenkreis dass ich bei
weitem nicht der einzige bin die
radikale
transformationspolitik ich würde auch
sagen Abbau und rückbaupolitik in
unserem Land die da gerade maßgeblich
von grün aber eben auch den anderen
Parteien geduldet vonstatten geht
erschreckt mich immer mehr und ich frage
mich in anderen Ländern und ich bekomme
aus der Nähe von Frankreich aus
Baden-Württemberg wir hatten Frankreich
vor der Haustür in so einem Land wie
Frankreich werden die Bürger glaube ich
schon längst auf der Straße wenn wenn es
solche radikalen Pläne die
offensichtlich zu lassen auch der
einfachen Leute und unsere
Wirtschaftsstandorts gehen umgesetzt
werden sollen und ich frage mich die
Deutschen sind
sehr geduldig aber irgendwann muss die
Stimmung denke ich auch mal kippen und
ich glaube da bin ich bei ihnen schon
Herr Stahl
diese Inschrift auf dem Reichstag dem
deutschen Volker an diese Inschrift muss
man einige dieser Leute tatsächlich
lautstark erinnern glaube ich sind eine
deutsch-französischen Grenze
aufgewachsen was unterscheidet in die
deutschen von den Franzosen
na die Franzosen die waren ja schon
immer schnell dabei
Französische Revolution kennt man ja aus
den Geschichtsbüchern wenn sie mit ihren
Herrschern nicht zufrieden waren dass
dann kurzer Prozess gemacht wurde das in
dieser radikalen Form will ich das
überhaupt gar nicht also bitte nicht
falsch verstehen
gar nicht weder gutheißen noch fordern
da kommen dann nämlich auch nicht immer
die richtigen danach die macht also die
Französische Revolution wollen wir nicht
in Deutschland arbeiten
mega Streik verkaufen das geht bei denen
als Mittagspausen aber sie wollen wir
wollen aber jetzt doch nicht noch mehr
Streits in Deutschland haben oder
vielleicht auch aber vielleicht sollten
dann mal die richtigen Dreiecken bisher
streiten oder öffentliche Dienst er
sollte den streiten
also nicht die metallische Musik
naja
vielleicht auch mal in der
Energieindustrie die ja bei der die die
Opfer ist davon ich meine ich frage mal
warum haben wir Deutschen anscheinend so
wenig Feuer in uns wenn man sich mal
plattformuliert so für mich
oder wir beantworten oder wir
beantworten erstmal die Frage ob
vielleicht Herr Stahl ein französisches
Herz in sich hat und kein deutsches
kann nicht sein also vielleicht liegt es
ein bisschen an meinen ganz späten
ungarischen Wurzeln dass ich einfach ein
Hostel Ungerechtigkeit Gefühl habe wenn
man die Menschen die Menschen vor allen
Dingen Bürger die Menschen irgendwie im
Stich lässt und vergisst und dann habe
ich jemand der sagt wenn ich es selber
vormache kann ich das auch von anderen
verlangen oder zumindestens erwarten
aber wenn ich es selber nicht vor mache
dann habe ich gar nicht den Mund
aufzumachen oder meiner Sprache weil
entscheiden D sie sagen dass sie sagen
sie predigen Wasser und saufen
Champagner ja und alle sollten die
machen nur mehr und ich bin da wirklich
bei Ihnen wie lange geht denn der Krug
noch zum Boden die Franzosen werden
schon lange draußen ich persönlich
glaube bloß vielleicht geht es so lange
bis es dann wirklich zu ganz schlimm
Dingen kommt und die sollten wir
eigentlich verhindern weil
die Arbeit ich sehe das genauso wenn das
so weitergeht gehen die großen Betriebe
einfach weil es lukrativer ist weg damit
schaffen wir Arbeitsplätze nur nicht bei
uns und wir bleiben dann zurück und
wendet ein paar radikalen Menschen die
eine Ideologie vertreten wollen dass wir
eine Postkutschen rumrennen und
Brunnenwasser trinke das hat eine schöne
Camping Mentalität aber passt nicht für
ein Land was auf auf Wirtschaft
aufgebaut ist und hier vor einigen
Haufen Menschen mit Mitarbeiter
dranhängt wir reden ja hier nicht von
irgendwas
Menschen mit Leben Familie und was hier
gerade passiert ist extrem gefährlich es
ist ein siede Kessel der da aufbrennt
und ich komme ja nur mal aus dem
Brennpunkt das Berliner Köln und ganz
ehrlich diese Silvester die wir da
gesehen haben ja die können ja auch
überall passieren und genau das wollen
wir nicht wir genau das wollen wir nicht
und die Polizei sondern das durchdrücken
und wir den Kopf dafür hinhalten für
diese Politik warum und das war doch
sehr schön zu sehen wir haben und Bürger
in Binz in Rügen in einem sehr hohen
Ecke wir haben die denn reagiert als
Habig und Scholz darauf gekommen sind
doch mit Entrüstung und wenn Küche sehr
wenige da und die haben gut also das
wenn man sich das mal anschaut und ich
alles war noch wenige da muss man sagen
es fehlt also aber die Stimmung ist doch
eher eher Resignation also man hört von
vielen Leuten die sich Sorgen machen und
die auch wirklich unzufrieden sind und
man hat hier wirklich das Gefühl hier
ist eine Regierung an der Macht die ist
mit sich selbst beschäftigt aber hat
wirklich die Interessen des Landes und
der Bevölkerung irgendwie vollkommen aus
dem Blick verlassen
sie haben heute schon ein paar
historische Vergleiche gemacht also um
die Klüngeleien ging wir haben jetzt
hier am Tisch würde ich sagen alle das
Gefühl dass es schlimm ist dass die
Menschen resignieren dass die Ampel
nicht gut ist war das denn immer anders
also ist es heute besonders schlimm oder
würden Sie sagen die Politik war schon
immer irgendwie schwierig in Frankreich
gibt's ja praktisch heute keine
Gewerkschaften mehr also Gewerkschaften
gibt's nur noch im öffentlichen Dienst
der Rest ist völlig eigentlich
organisationslos und dann gibt es
Frankreich ein sehr hoch große Zahl an
Krieg her Beschäftigten und dort gibt es
Privileg für die diejenigen die normalen
Arbeitsverhältnis haben die verteidigen
natürlich ihre Privilegien bei der
französischen Bahn und dann spricht sich
natürlich dieser dieser Unmut jetzt über
diese Rentenreform als Beispiel
durch das heißt es gibt im Grunde haben
diese Leute die Straße gehen und sich
mit der Polizei prügeln haben überhaupt
gar keine Chance mehr in das normale
politische System eingebunden zu werden
wie funktioniert das bei uns früher das
hätten wir immer soziale Marktwirtschaft
das sind kommen jetzt wieder die bösen
Lobbyisten wir hatten wir haben
Gewerkschaften wir haben
Unternehmensverbände wir haben
handwerksverbände wir haben Industrie
und Handelskammern das deutsche System
ist total verschachtelt und alle diese
Gruppen repräsentieren Teil dieser
Bevölkerung also meinetwegen IG Metall
immer noch eine millionenfacharbeiter
und wenn es jetzt z.B zum Maßnahmen
kommt zur Veränderung kommt dann
organisiert man das gemeinsam es gab zum
Beispiel in den 70er 80er Jahren große
stahlkrisen Ruhrgebiet wir haben die das
gemeldet die haben das gemanagt weil
sich die wesentliche Akteure
zusammengesetzt haben die haben auch die
sozialpolitischen Interessen der
strahlarbeiter vertreten im Bergbau gab
es immer dieses schöne Wort keiner wird
ins bergfreie fallen das ist auch
eingehalten worden und wenn man es also
zum Beispiel zu Strukturveränderung gab
zum Beispiel Leute sicher sein ich habe
funktionierendes soziales Netz und alle
Akteure hatten auch das Gefühl die
Politik hört uns zu die eigentliche
Katastrophe die du Habeck hier zu machen
oder dergleichen ist wenn dann die zum
Beispiel das Gewerbe
Heizungsbau und die große Firmen dann in
einem Artikel zum deutlich machen der
interessiert sich eigentlich gar nicht
für unsere Interessen unser Anliegen
egal noch schlimmer weil auch noch mit
dem klüngelsee ja weil nee das Problem
ist der hat überhaupt keinen Sinn so
jung für dieses deutsche Verbände System
was dieses Land 70 Jahre lang so stabil
gehalten hat da musst du natürlich auch
die Interessen von einzelnen Akteuren
Rücksicht nehmen das sind nicht einfach
nur böse Unternehmen sondern System
genau
Umweltverbände diese ganzen nicht
Regierungsorganisationen Fridays for
future und weißt du was und das ist das
eigentliche Problem und wenn das bei uns
zusammen klappt dann fallen wir ins
bergfrei dann kann es wirklich passieren
wie im testen oder System nie so richtig
funktionierte dass die Leute dann halt
AFD wählen
völlig apathisch werden und auch auf
andere Ideen kommen aber nicht mehr in
das System integriert sind aber komm
Stichwort Stichwort Wahlen kommen wir
hier nochmal zur königsfrage zum Ende
ihrer These Herr Gräber wird es denn
Neuwahlen geben wie steht es um die
Ampel hält die Ampel der Druck aus also
diese Affäre kreilchen was ich so so
höre wobei da auch viel Gerüchte gerade
dabei sind könnte tatsächlich noch
wirklich zu einem Problem werden und
zwar nicht nur für Habicht sondern auch
für die gesamte aber Finanzierung
gesagt er findet die Vorwürfe
unverhältnismäßig das sieht ja fast nach
zusammenhalten
erstmal ja die große Frage ist Scholz
der ja oft sich nicht so richtig
irgendwann auch mal
in irgendeiner Form eingreifen wird
werden wir sehen das Problem ist alle
drei Parteien haben Angst von Neuwahlen
weil sie nach jetzigen Umfang stand
keine Mehrheit mehr hätten genau das ist
das Problem aber auch und deswegen
befürchte ich fast dass die noch sehr
lange oder noch Halt bis zur nächsten
regulären weil daran festhalten werden
wir machen mal eine Frage in die Runde
ja Nein Spiel wer ist hier natürlich für
neuweil fangen wir an zu meiner linken
Seite ja Nein Neuwahlen wollen
mit sich geben ich weiß gar nicht wie
die wären